you wrote this song zoey i i really
you call it zowie i think cause well no
no it's no because
it should be zoey originally it was
david bowie
so it was owie bowie and then people
americanized it and then he became david
bowie but originally he was zoe bowie
i can't believe he wanted to be like jim
bowie the knife i can't believe you're
telling me that i worked with a radio
guy
who used to coat and now here's a song
from david bowie
and i pulled him aside and i said listen
i i said maybe you don't care but the
guy's name is david bowe he goes no
in england they say david bowie and i
went this [ __ ] guy
i don't care what they say anymore bowie
oh so it was bowie so technically it's
zowie bowie yeah
wally if you're listening you were right
i see so you call it zowie because it
rhymes with bowie
yeah because you remember he named his
son who's now the director duncan jones
he named him zowie right um she was a
little tribute to david
and and you loved david bowie loved him
when when i was writing this song
the opening chord sequence reminded me
like the kind of chords they would he'd
do a lot of weird inversions
right and so i started thinking about
david and then it was probably not too
long after he passed or he was just in
the air
and so he kind of rode shotgun with me
when i was writing the song
i was sort of meditating on in one part
of my brain about david and the times
that i met him
and then i was writing the song and this
other thing this kind of self-reflective
thing
and so when it finished it felt like i
had to sort of tip my cap to him
it's like a very personal way to say
thank you
yeah man to talk about thank you i
remember he never liked the album but
remember when he put out live from
philadelphia yeah the 74 uh
that was my favorite album that's great
album i love that album and i told him
and he was like i hate that album
and uh i was like i was so shocked and
then he sent me an autographed uh album
uh you know that which is very gracious
yeah how did you get a relationship
going with david bowie that's all i ever
wanted
uh didn't get to know him too well
because he seemed very very private
right maybe that's the way he was with
certain people i don't know um
you just loved his music i loved him too
he was such a good
person like wow he just astounded me
with who he was when did you get to meet
him
we did some television shows and some
and he was on the same
label as me so i'd run into him here and
there and have a chat and
and and then eventually he asked me to
be on his 50th birthday party show which
is at madison square garden which has
now become this kind of legendary show
where he had
lou reed was on it and all these amazing
people were on it when you meet a guy
like that
and obviously as a musician and we all
love his music but you know you you know
music on a higher level and i'll ever
know
do you go omino like i don't know what
to say to him or do you
start talking about music or do you try
not to talk about music so that he won't
think you're a dick
you try not to be a fan boy yeah and so
how do you pull that off what do you
think it's very difficult
i did i would talk with him about books
and anything but music because
it's just i didn't want to be that guy
i'll tell you one quick thing though
because
um it's a little insight into his mind
so when i did his 50th uh
birthday party he had me do all the
young dudes with him
yeah i mean incredible song and what's
amazing is he you know
matt the hoople released it he didn't
even release his own version that's how
good he was at the point he had hits
with other people
anyway so i said to him why'd you pick
uh all the young dudes for me
he goes oh well you know there's that
line about billy's picking stars off his
face so i thought of you
out of mind i'll take that forever
you